I never thought that four years of
undergrad and a two-year master's degree
would eventually mean that I am actually
professional gate holder but here I am
proud of it you know I mean dreams
really do come true
[Applause]
[Music]
about there'd be two money to do
anything so it's not fun the calves are
fed now run to the house change and get
the kids to their school yeah one of
those mornings
gotta love Monday before we get into
skull and to make a pit stop to get a
drink miss Jackson's country boys does
what manner she said what she said she's
not even on I said but she gave me a
penny she gave you a penny okay that's
one cent yes since you it's one cent
over a dollar it costs 99 cents oh she
gave you better she said she was gonna
give me nine cents
okay baby so got the kids dropped off
getting ready to go feed in the mud when
my husband gets back he went to help a
friend who has dairy steers to take to
market and needed an extra trailer so
when he gets back we'll talk on the mud
we are enjoying a mild 55 degree day
even though it's rained an inch and a
half this weekend and feeding is
absolutely horrendous because of the mud
and because we have we still have our
cows and calves and smaller Lots because
they're not quite done calving basically
almost and as soon as they are then we
will work I'll run them through the
chute and we'll work them and put them
out on some larger pasture but you
believe how fast that little monkey
drinks that milk
you're out done look at that anyway so
that's what we're doing today got the
kids delivered on school co-op sweet
home school haven't really talked about
that but we do that so on Mondays they
go to a co-op and mom gets a day off to
do other things like writing because I'm
a freelance writer for a progressive
farmer and
Digital magazine called AG now and for
that magazine I also record what I write
so if you don't like to read you can
click a button and let me read it to you
so I got that done today and it is some
pictures I don't know y'all it's just
always a lot going on here anyway we'll
head out in the mud in a minute on this
I don't need that I'm just going up the
road I almost forgot though that I need
to make a phone call business phone call
and we don't have a landline because
it's not working and our cell phone
service is really crappy so I go to the
barn to conduct business in my truck so
that's amazing
yeah a rural internet and cell phone
service still no hope one day we'll get
by okay off its time done and the wind
is whipping out there which is good
because when the wind whips the mud
starts to dry I mean hopefully and I
almost forgot that somebody is coming to
get corn tonight that hasn't been bagged
yet so I guess he gets to do that and
there's an M in my way okay one down
nine to go ah I don't know if you
remember but a while back I showed um my
husband picking corn with his old corn
picker well this is after this is what's
left after probably I don't know 400 or
so bags that we sold at least yeah we
still got plenty and this is for deer
hunters somebody's gonna ask me that
it's for deer hunters so yeah here we go
[Music]
yeah don't even act like you're tired
alright that's done ten bags that need
to be closed but um I don't know how to
do it my husband has this fancy little
knot he does and I haven't mastered it
so I figured I'd leave something for him
to do yeah there we go
everybody's hungry we're a little later
feeding today a lot later my husband had
to take a load of cab to market for a
neighbor yeah this money obviously this
is not ideal we have another way right
now we would do it but we do the best we
can with what we have
I've seen it worse but this isn't isn't
good
and another fun thing over the last few
years I have been able to add something
else to my resume gate holding
extraordinaire I never thought that four
years of undergrad and a two-year
master's degree would eventually mean
that I am actually professional gate
holder but here I am proud of it you
know I mean dreams really do come true
and the Sun came out maybe for more than
30 seconds and the winds blowing so
that's what we need
[Applause]
[Music]
and this will do it pretty van y'all
[Applause]
[Music]
you